the only way to catch this crew is in
the act
you're going new york
turn up the issue i'm dying to give you
the problem you practically begging for
the opinion of the department if james
knight wasn't hunting bank robbers
he'd be robbing thanks knight might be
rough around the edges
but he's a good cop this crew is tight
they move like a team you got a theory
all roads lead back to a businessman
goes by winner
i hope i'm not uh interrupting what can
i do you for yeah a lot of ex-pros i
like a couple of them for a messy job
do anything about that not to the best
of my recollection
think real hard
fbi cia atf all have open cases on
winners and two city cops from la walk
in here and they think they're gonna
handle the case
that cop served in the marines seems to
have some disciplinary hearing every
year i was thinking
but if we try your
way night is the most dangerous piece on
the board hello it can strike when you
least expect it
are you uh trying to be funny no
i can take you out whenever i want
wherever i want
[Music]
how can you be at the wrong place at the
right time all the time
[Music]
trick or treat mother
you